so the math is mathing with this question
I'm 32 I have three children
they are 12 9 and 5
which means I had my first baby when I was 20
and it wasn't exactly part of the life plan
it was a happy accident
it was an unplanned miracle
not gonna go so far as to say it was immaculate concession
because that would be a lie
but did you know that birth control is only like 98
99% effective there is a very
very small chance that it doesn't work every time and
I can attest to that
so the story goes
I was 19 in my first year of university and I went to my uncle's wedding
and at my uncle's wedding was a wedding singer and I thought he was cute
he thought I was cute we started hanging out and really
really liked each other and after a pretty short period of time
I was getting sick I was waking up sick
I was throwing up in the mornings and I was like
oh no I just have a tummy bag and his mum was like hmm
sounds like she's pregnant
maybe she should take a test and I was like
I'm so not pregnant there is absolutely no way that I'm pregnant
I'm so not pregnant
I'm gonna prove to everyone how not pregnant I am by taking a test
so went to the university nurse
and I took a pregnancy test and I found out that I was pregnant
and I was so surprised
which now with my like actually fully developed frontal lobe
I'm like you fkn idiot it was so obvious but anyway
so I actually got pregnant when I was 19
but I didn't find out till I had just turned 20 and that was when I got sick
and we were just madly in love
loved each other
loved the baby decided to go ahead with it and even get married so
I think back at this and I'm like
you were so naive and so young and just
just full of hope and optimism for life
and love and the world and all of the things
but anyway that's what we did
and we got married and we had our baby and we were super happy
and two years later we had another baby so meanwhile
I like I said was at university so I had done my first year
I found out I was pregnant in my second year
I finished my second year
and then I took the third year off and just stayed at home with the baby
and then I took my third year and I split it up over two years
so by the end of the second year
I had a toddler and I was breastfeeding a Newborn at my graduation
which was pretty fkn epic now that I think about it now
but at the time I was just super embarrassed
because I was already
a couple of years older than the rest of the kids in my graduating class
and I was heavily pregnant
and occasionally I would have to take my toddler to class with me and it just
I got a lot of stares do you know what I mean
but I was like whatever I'm here for a purpose
I'm here to get my degree and I did
I got the best grades and I worked really hard
and I will just say that like nothing makes you work hard like being a mum
you know what I mean
like you can effectively use your time because you know how precious time is
whereas before when I was at uni
I was just sort of fkn around and finding out anyway
so then I had two children
2 and under and it was a lot
it was a lot I was like wow
this is um so many kids
and also
we had no money because we were both students when we started our family
and so we were just trying to work and earn and pay the bills
and feed our children and clothe them
and all of that sort of thing
and then after about three years was like I want another baby
and then anyway so I went and made one
and that was when we got my daughter
so there's a four year age gap between No. 2 and number three
and that was it for me like family done
so I had finished having babies by the time I was 27
and actually now that I'm in my 30s
I struggle so much to think that my baby days are behind me
because I am always so clucky
I'm a very maternal person
I absolutely love babies I love toddlers
I love breastfeeding I love all of it
and to think that like I'm still so young and that part of me is over
but then also the flipside of that is
I get to really enjoy spending time with the children that I do have
and they are absolutely my best friends
and because they're a bit older
they're really easy to do cool shit with
like shit that you can't do with small children anyway
I'm getting a bit off topic now
so that is roughly the story of how I got pregnant
ha ha well
actually there's another story of how I got pregnant
but that is the story of how I became a mother at 20
if you have any questions
lay them on me because I don't really know what you wanna know